I'm Sally Lockwood and on this special
edition of The Sky News Daily The
Fallout from Dominic Robb's resignation
he stepped down as Deputy Prime Minister
and Justice secretary after he was found
her bullied staff while working as a
cabinet minister
we'll be talking about what the
consequences could be for Rishi sunak
who ordered the five-month investigation
into these bullying allegations just
weeks after moving into Downing Street
and who'd had loyal support from Dominic
Robb during his leadership campaign
against Liz Truss
let's go through all of that with our
political correspondent Joe Pike so
great to have you with us
um a pretty dramatic 24 hours in
Westminster let's just start with
Dominic Robb's resignation letter
clearly not happy talk us through what
he said
unhappy Sally and also interesting that
it has taken 24 hours after the report
was delivered to Downing Street and Mr
Rob to get a response clearly uh he is
unhappy with not just what Mr Tully has
said in this report but its implications
for his career and in this pretty long
two-page uh resignation letter he he
hits out at the precedent he argues this
could set for the relationship between
ministers and their civil servants at
the same time he's also written a long
article for the telegraph an opinion an
opinion piece setting out uh his views
and his frustrations so perhaps he's
making the most of the last uh 24 hours
to try and get his narrative out and his
narrative out very quickly as soon as
the news dropped that he was leaving his
top job yeah I mean this investigation
Joe just to remind listeners has been
going on for what five months now it's
taken 10 24 hours for a response and the
response interestingly was a resignation
not a sacking what do you make of all
that it's always difficult with prime
ministers whether to decide to uh sack
somebody or let them resign effectively
the same thing is happening but the sort
of Optics are different Dominic Raab is
a close Ally of Rishi sunak and has been
by his side through some of the pretty
uh difficult moments in the leadership
contest last summer there were moments
where a Dominic Rob was a sort of
outrider on the airwaves defending Rishi
Suna and attacking Liz truss pretty
heavily even when it became clear from
opinion polls that Mr sunak was going to
lose that race so he's somebody who's
made his loyalty to Richardson very a
very very clear even before he got into
number 10 and was rewarded with that
Deputy PM job so I don't think Rishi
sunak wants to to create an enemy but
also doesn't want to treat him too badly
one thing Prime Ministers usually think
about when they are looking into the HR
decisions around their cabinet table is
what it looks like not just the public
but to MPS too yet you don't want to
look like you're treating cabinet
ministers badly who've been loyal to you
because it doesn't necessarily set a
great a precedent it's not what MPS want
to see before we get on to the article
that Dominic Robb has written in the
telegraph making his uh views extremely
clear let's just go through at the
allegations that have been made against
Dominic Robb Dominic Robb has been a
cabinet minister through Theresa May
Boris Johnson now Richard sunax
Administration and there have been
allegations of bad behavior throughout I
would argue his career at the top of
government but not necessarily that
clear allegations uh Rishi sunak asked
Adam tolly the senior Casey to
investigate and he has found that
Dominic Robb's Behavior towards civil
servants at points was intimidating was
persistently aggressive that he said
that the work of civil servants appoints
was utterly useless and woe for and that
some of this Behavior could be seen to
have been undermining and humiliating
but as Dominic raw points out himself in
his own letter uh not all of the
allegations were upheld by Adam Tolley
and there was also evidence that some of
the civil servants trying to contribute
to the case against Dominic Robb it
hadn't actually met him what I think is
the key point to remember on this is
where the definition of bullying was put
certainly the definition of bullying
adopted by Mr tolly the lawyer and by
Richardson that the Prime Minister was
pretty broad not relying on intent so
according to receive and Mr tolly
Dominic Rob didn't have to realize he
was a bullying for his behavior to
qualify as uh bullying whether he was
aware of it or not they argue there is
evidence of of bad behavior therefore
there was a breach of the ministerial
code and Dominic Raab had to leave his
job he says at the start of his letter I
called for the inquiry and undertook to
resign if it made any finding of
bullying whatsoever I believe it is
important to keep my word
but also he says later on while I feel
Duty bound to accept the outcome it
dismissed all but two of the claims
leveled against me I also believe that
it's adverse findings are flawed and set
a dangerous precedent for the conduct of
good government he's basically arguing
ministers need to hold civil servants to
account if their work isn't up to
scratch they need to be told certainly
he seems to have been implying in his
interactions with civil servants they
were prepared he has high standards
maybe thought there was some sort of
cultural resistance within the Civil
Service that was calling it out and
feels that he has been unjustly treated
for doing so and certainly Joe Dominic
Robb has taken the time to write more
than a thousand words uh in the Daily
Telegraph this morning Friday at the
time of recording uh tell us what he
says in that article well he Echoes what
he said in his resignation letter but
also I think is frustrated with the
timeline line of of these complaints
that complaints from a vast wave of his
time in government have been all uh put
together he says in the article normal
Rules of Evidence and procedural
fairness were disapplied for example
there is a three-month time limit for
bringing bullying claims in an
employment tribunal while standard
internal human resources practice is to
avoid unreasonable delay because late
claims are unfair and on unreliable in
my case Dominic Rob writes all the
complaints were stored up for over three
months most over eight months some for
over four years and then submitted he
argues in a coordinated way certainly
richardsonac seems to partly agree with
this argument because in his response to
Dominic Rob resilation letter he says
it's clear there have been shortcomings
in the historic process and the Prime
Minister has asked the cabinet office
this department at the center of
government to lick it look into
historic complaints I suppose the prime
ministers may be saying he's concerned
at the timeliness of complaints allies
of Dominic Raab do argue that this has
been a bit of a a hit job a lot of
different complaints over many years
have been put together have been
coordinated by certain members of the
civil service to bring him down those
people I suppose allies of Dominic
Robert would argue they have succeeded
but we should also point out that what
Mr tolly has said is that uh there has
been evidence of intimidating
persistently aggressive behavior
interestingly also that Mr Tolley says
that Dominic Robb's Behavior changed
once these allegations emerged and the
investigation started of course we now
realize that that of course was far too
late for the former deputy pm
the counterclaim Joe you know will be
Dominic Robb was a tough task master and
you need a thick skin to be a civil
servant you need a thick skin for a lot
of Industries you need a thick skin to
work in a youth room as I'm sure you've
experienced Joe and you know Dominic
Robert said that this decision sets a
dangerous precedent for officials to
Target ministers which would paralyze
government your response uh to that
thought from Dominic Robb well there are
uh many ministers who do feel that
changing the direction of government is
a long slow frustrating process it's
almost like turning in oil tanker around
and they would argue or some would argue
that not all civil servants isn't
necessarily on board with the reform
plans of each government Mr Rob has
seemingly argued that some officials he
met with and worked with weren't
prepared for meetings that he is a
grafter hard worker working incredibly
long hours weekends at points he he
wanted high standards and and those were
not always met I suppose though we
haven't actually seen many other members
of the cabinet face these sorts of
allegations and we've seen Dominic Robb
face his allegations from three separate
departments and an independent
investigator upholds uh some of them so
I suppose there must be a way to create
change in government and maybe not to
keep the Civil Service on site but not
to offend some civil servants to a
degree that they're putting in these uh
complaints complaints that to some
extent have been upheld and of course
there is um subjectivity to all of this
uh you know so what what could be
bullying to one person may just be uh
speaking you know sharply to another but
I I suppose uh the bottom line is that
uh there has been an independent
investigator Adam Tolley Casey who has
found uh The Bullying claims to have
been up hell Joe yeah and the definition
of of bullying he adopted was broad but
that's something the Prime Minister
adopted to uh Dominic Raab
um did uh reach that level uh of uh
bullying he wasn't necessarily aware of
it uh he wasn't
um intent wasn't necessarily proved but
that didn't matter to either Adam Tully
or Rishi sunak that's why Dominic Robb
has left government although we should
point out he has been at a top level
across multiple Ministries he's been
Deputy pm to two prime ministers Boris
Johnson and Rishi sunak served as
foreign secretary for two years so
clearly some prime ministers have seen
him as a talented Minister somebody they
wanted not just in their team but
towards the top of their team deputizing
at key points we therefore assume that
Richard will find him
a bit of a loss to his administration
Oliver Dowden has now replaced uh Mr
robber's Deputy Prime Minister and Alex
chalk replaced uh him in the role as a
Justice uh secretary But ultimately the
bad headlines over many weeks and months
uh Richardson wanted to avoid especially
as he said on the steps of Downing
Street when he took over as PM that his
government would have integrity
professionalism and accountability at
every level certainly a Dominic Raab has
been held to account and that has led to
him losing his job
yeah you make a good point Joe uh Rishi
sunak came in uh saying he was going to
clean up politics this would all be
about transparency he was going to have
a government of Integrity how do you
think that's going for him
uh well I don't think it's ideal that uh
in less than a year he's had three
cabinet ministers uh leave their roles
in gun Williamson Nadeem Sahari and in
Dominic Raab and the fact that the
bigger question for his leadership is
why he appointed some people when when
there were uh allegations already
swirling around them certainly in terms
of Dominic Robb and his a conduct
towards officials but also in terms of
the Home Secretary swella bravaman and
how she had dealt with sensitive
information and shared it Beyond uh
officials and people within government
somebody outside uh government and uh
that's a sort of constant debate there
it doesn't look great but I suppose the
fact that these three people have left
government not uh stayed in their job
shows that certainly deals with these
sorts of complaints very separately to
Boris Johnson of course there are
allegations of bullying against pretty
tell them the home of secretary Boris
Johnson kept her and posting in that
situation it was his advisor or
ministerial standards who ended up
leaving their job so British who knocks
Administration certainly operates in a a
different way regards to standards even
if the headlines I'm sure will be felt
in a pretty painful way by the Prime
Minister these headlines he'd have
wanted to have avoided and the 24 hours
of sort of Silence after the report was
submitted to Richardson act doesn't look
like he was acting in the most decisive
manner even though his advisors argue it
was a long report 48 pages based on 66
interviews 44 pieces of written evidence
and therefore he needed the time to go
through it carefully before deciding
what happened next
so at the time of recording Joe Rishi
sunak has been prime minister for around
six months he has lost three cabinet
ministers in that time
do you think this will blow open new
discussions about culture at Westminster
I certainly think there are allies of
Dominic Raab within the conservative
party on the back benches and perhaps in
government two who feel that he's been
badly treated and feel that perhaps a
civil service cabal brought him down and
they could do it to others I suppose
other people perhaps in different
political parties would argue that is a
bit of a conspiracy theory
and if you treat people well even if you
are pushing for significant reform in
government you have nothing to fear
there will be a debate uh going on
within uh Westminster perhaps not that
uh publicly But ultimately these
allegations come from three separate
departments an independent lawyer has I
found evidence of intimidating behavior
on the parts of a Dominic Robb that he
was persistently aggressive and even
though not all complaints were upheld
and some people trying to contribute uh
to these cases had never met Dominic
Raab the conclusions show that he's
broken the ministerial code and
therefore he had to leave his job
ultimately it's Richard sunak who's the
Arbiter of the ministerial code and he's
acted uh relatively decisively in
removing uh his closest Ally some would
argue from the top of government
and this is all you know a bit of a gift
for labor isn't it Dominic Robb the
Deputy Prime Minister having to resign
amid bullying allegations what have they
been saying
well for labor this fees into their
argument of chaos at the top of
government of course they have been a
leaping on this pretty quickly arguing
that this shows at the weakness of Rishi
sunak not just in appointing uh Dominic
Robb in the first place when when some
had expressed uh concerns but also
taking quite so long to get rid of it I
suppose allies of Richardson that would
argue look we appointed an independent a
lawyer he took his time and we acted
within 24 hours but certainly at the
labor party have jumped on this to try
and uh put forward the narrative they
have put forward pretty consistently in
recent months about chaos about Richard
sunak not being fit to govern the lib
Dems who I think have their eye on
Dominic Robb's marginal seat of Isha
have also been trying to make the most
of this
um making it clear that they uh think
that they can uh win that seat it could
have been a big scout for them to win at
the next general election potentially a
big Portillo moment that of course won't
necessarily happen now because we don't
know if Dominic Rob will stand
definitely at the next election even if
he did because he is no longer serving
in Rishi sunak's government isn't such a
significant scalp to win certainly
though opposition party's trying to to
make their most and feeding into these
arguments of chaos that I'm sure will
see them use in the coming months right
up until the general election
and of course they're also using it as
an opportunity to cast doubt over Rishi
sunax Authority and his own government
that Dominic Raab resigned instead of
him being sack Joe do you think that's
significant
it's a point that they are perfectly
entitled to make there is always though
a judgment made by Prime Ministers over
sacking people which potentially could
be seen by Tories on the back benches as
treating allies badly or letting them do
the a decent thing and resign which is
soon like seemingly here has let Dominic
Raab resign let him in some ways try and
control the narrative with this
resignation letter and this long article
in the telegraph But ultimately he has
lost his job and Rishi sunak has
overseen that and therefore he would
argue I'm sure that standards of
Integrity of professionalism of
accountability have been upheld at the
top of government and he's moved swiftly
to a point uh ministers to replace them
Oliver dowden's Deputy pm and Alex chalk
the Justice secretary and a final
thought from you Joe if I may obviously
it's not been a great 24 hours for Rishi
sunak certainly not for Dominic Robb and
this may rumble on for some time how
much do you think it's actually going to
cause long-term damage either at the
local elections just next month or
longer term in the general election in
the next 18 months I think by the time
of the general election people will have
forgotten about Dominic Robb certainly
though it's not the ideal Prelude to the
local elections which is the first
chance we have really to see
intellectual terms the impact of Rishi
sunax leadership and sort of
post-partygate view of Voters even
though we should say the local elections
last time around four years ago were in
the dying day of Theresa Mays a
Premiership when the conservatives
weren't in a good place either they are
of course a moment of Jeopardy for
Russia sumac but also a moment where Kia
Salma the labor leader is being judged
he needs to prove uh that he is making
progress is is building support among
voters and therefore building support
with councils running their seats
gaining control of councils yes this
isn't the ideal prelude for for Rishi
Sue Nick yes it allows kyostarma Ed
Davey the lib Dem leader Hamza Yousaf
the SMP leader Scotland's first minister
to try and put forward this argument of
chaos and slipping standards within a
Westminster I suppose rishunak's allies
will hope that in the coming couple of
weeks this story will slightly dissipate
and they will be able to focus on local
issues that are at the center of a
voter's minds they hope when going to
the ballot boxes and thinking about who
should be running the local councils who
should be looking after local public
services and Bin Collections and
potholes certainly there's rarely a dull
moment at Westminster Joe thanks so much
for walking us through
my thanks to Joe Pike and to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Sally Lockwood The Producers were Alex
Eden and David chupacupaku our editor is
Philly Beaumont